so let's just recap here
this is my last season on The Voice
what Niall Horan imitates Blake Shelton
not once but twice during The Voice
season 23 Premiere he was just about to
go did my last season on this show
it'll be an honor and a privilege I'm
feeling like a father-son type bond with
Nile there you go mostly because he
disappoints me a lot it's an amazing
experience the Irish singer and newest
voice coach isn't afraid to go head to
head with the country crooner in his
final go around in the red spinning
chairs I'm working with some of the
biggest songwriters and producers on the
planet bragger I'm not your coach
this is my first season and you're the
best thing that's walked out here so
good to meet you I think it's better to
meet you hey that's just another thing
that she and I have in common I love you
too thank you Dad I'm excited to get
someone his country on my team I think
that's actually my first goal what is
the strategy to try to keep him for
winning number 10 and you one
as Blake attempts to take home his final
win he's also milking the fact it's his
farewell tour I've mentioned it uh
a couple of times I'll be honored for
you to be on the last team Blake this is
my last season as a coach on this show
wouldn't that be cool have Ross right
off into the sunset with me on my last
on your last time I'm ever going to have
on this show so I just wanted them to be
aware that it was going to be my last
season in case you didn't know that
people that auditioned are aware Blake's
an OG coach beginning his journey on The
Voice in 2011. I gotta go with Blake
I love beating the other coaches it's
it's what they pay me to do 12 years and
23 Seasons later the country starts
hanging up his coaching boots Blake
predicts it's not going to hit him until
the very end that's it I'm never going
to beg somebody to be on my team again
I'm never going to hit this button again
and uh it kind of hit it it surprised me
how it hit me you know I didn't cry or
anything because I don't cry
try
but I probably it's probably going to be
an emotional night that last night I
mean my God it's been 23 see 12 years
it's unbelievable it's to all the life
that's happened and and I met my wife on
there you know it just everything good
that could come from something like that
it I maxed it out
[Music]
foreign